how was I mean honestly how was it how
did you do it because I know you kind of
just went away for a while when he
passed was that like I didn't go well
Instagram I don't have Instagram okay
let's say this out loud that's a funny
[__] account okay whoever that guy is
he's scumbag I'm gonna stop following
him don't follow him he really I I
someone sent me that he wrote I need to
go away
yeah that's not me I don't have an
Instagram account Instagram no but you
it's okay that you think that but it's a
bummer to me that someone you know he
posts pictures this is official no any
and he post pictures of my dead friends
and writes miss you buddy like I I want
you know like I don't want to be violent
but like this dude deserves
I've tried Instagram won't even take him
down as I'm I'm uh it obviously gets me
pissed off but anyway I didn't go
anywhere no that's some dude
how did you deal with it I'm okay with
death man death doesn't [__] me up I
mean it doesn't no it was expected it
was sort of like you were yeah I mean it
was listen man you know he wasn't happy
at the end of his life and he was having
a rough time and you know part of it was
I don't want to say a relief but relief
that he wouldn't have to suffer anymore
you know it's like you know
it's like he's like a he's a um he was a
a like a quarter horse who couldn't run
anymore you know what I mean or like a
Thor better he had a thoroughbred who
couldn't run anymore it's like it's
that's no yeah he's spent his whole life
being active and running around and then
he's like jammed up for the last few
years of his life it's hard to watch you
know
um but um
but yeah man I think I think it's
important to to be um
to get older and understand and we all
got to deal with death man and I think
that's a hard thing for me is it yeah
yeah I mean it's like I'm not to bring
it up again but I said hey your your dog
passed you know like and you were like
oh thanks for bringing that up it's like
I was kidding no no I know you were but
I know it it was it was hard it's like
man I had a dog that was
I know they were talking about dogs now
but uh you know as hard as it is to lose
someone that was so massive and so
important and
um
it was time man you know he wasn't
living a good life anymore you know same
thing with my mom man when she passed it
was like she wasn't living a good life
anymore right neither was my dog that's
that's why I brought it up I and I
didn't want to compare my parents to my
dog but I had you know you remember I
had the greatest dog of all time I think
when that dog died I'd never been sadder
in my life yeah but I was ready and I
was like she can't walk anymore like I'm
not I'm not this is a dog that jumps in
the air and catches balls like well you
know I feel like you know we we put dogs
to sleep that's the nice thing to do we
don't do that with people we keep them
alive
right right then I'm gonna do that all
right